herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
leute mit trend ist wahrscheinlich
mittlerweile schon wieder vorbei aber
auch ich habe mir ein amazon
überraschungspaket gestellt bin ich
nämlich übertrieben cool deshalb ist mir
auch egal ob das noch gut ist oder nicht
es ist cool ist mit mega cool
doch das ist also dass das prinzip
funktioniert folgendermaßen man zahlt
einen festen betrag und die entweder 10
euro 15 und 20 euro bis zu cannabis 70
gibt es eigentlich auch
überraschungspakete und klickt 30
restposten also produkte die von
irgendwelchen großen versandhäusern auf
amazon nicht losgeworden werden und
wegen wir also hier ist man ein paket
leute dieses ganzen paket das große
teile ich habe mich inklusive
versandkosten 9 euro 50 gekostet mega
spannend
das ist echt nicht leicht das schon mal
leichter falls ihr setzen willst dass
wir die anstrengung auf uns nehmen dass
man leicht bis auf bekommen und
vielleicht ist oder bin ich ja wir
gucken einfach nicht rein
wahrscheinlich wird der verein und
versuchst zu viel macht seine augen
zunächst mal aus was ich sehen konnte zu
fühlen
ich bin schon okay das sieht aus wie ein
schild von der mütze oder so ist eine
mütze bewegung
[Gelächter]
wem gehört dieser bob piloten mit ca
wenn du die es nicht rocksmith von
karneval cnet beck auch noch weiter
schließt netbackup emirats mit triflex
manzato krank reid er ist wieder da wer
heute sowieso eine person erfinde die
diese mütze immer auf 88 9 kommentare
junge ja bitte beruf hat jeder seine
tatkraft
dabei hätte ziehen einmal die kompetenz
der kontrolleur kommt nicht einmal ihr
video sie ist diese mütter papiere seien
leute wenn ihr den kontrolleuren opfer
sehen wollten den videos bloß auf jeden
fall leichter es geht so gut auf den
strecken und wir uns nächste woche post
in sachen sind übertrieben sind es gibt
bild hatte
es ist eine verrückte ist nur theorie
entwickelt ein alter brauch ich kein
held sein
die frage ist nicht einfach alle hasse
das was soll ich hasse dieses gefühl
dass ich zukünftig müssen wir die
aufziehen hat jeder seine verlag karten
das ist hier jetzt schon genug für diese
beiden dinge ich glaube ich behalte die
sache ohne scheiß und verwendet
welche videos wie können wir hier ich
habe die kommentare was ist als ob also
zum den stürmen gemacht es ist einfach
ein riesengroßer barth zum umhängen
chefkontrolleur erwarten
dabei ist wie das wäre schon das beste
wir hier auf meinem kanal rheinländer
ohne spaß 9 euro 50 jetzt gefühl ist
einfach so karnevalskostüm oder aber man
kann ja ich habe hierzu keine beiden
aufblasbaren gummi football stellt und
dafür neue euro bezahlt für seine
günstigste euro für so ein luftig was
für den fußball das sagen den fünf
spielern über java so von der qualität
her wie so ein wasser weiter hier bin
ich der dritte und nochmals nein bleiben
wir wissen echt nicht was drin ich hoffe
dass ich schon jetzt das tägliche flut
immer taktischen sachen zu deiner aus
witten eine blumenkette einfach anziehen
der einzelne blätter aber die haben
nicht die kameras noch offen
richtig auf was was man relativ oft
brauchen selben alter wie auch brauchst
du so rose besser auslasten ständig
deshalb bin ich so herr peter matic
bekommen hat mich gestern erst gefragt
wo kriege ich jetzt gleich rosenblätter
aus plastik hermann video ideen steht
übrigens raus victoria katarina die
haben das politische macht die theorien
kreditkarten 1 515 luftballons auf der
happy birthday stephan feck ich war
letztens bei luca als wir den franken
für java steht es riecht nach lakritz
giftig aber perfekt lesben lukaschenko
fehler gemacht
du kannst einfach nicht geschafft nötig
wären 20 gebäudes genommen hat es
probiert und sie angesteckt ist nicht
sicher den dreifachen normal so
verlieren wird ja okay ich poste auch
nicht mehr auf also einer der user
wieder was los
würdest du diesen peinlichen den bogen
weiter oder mehr weitergeben
ja ich würde sagen die heute vielleicht
mal aus spaß und sie machen einfach ist
die junge rose an der plastik großen
wir müssen nächste lange ist auch warum
kümmert ist aber okay leute wie meist
klappt auf dem tisch 25 jahren an
sehr gut was haben wir nächstes mal aus
wir möchten ganz seltsame verhalten so
tief dass bewunderung griechen die man
im normalen das meer
junge reporterin hey boss hier bin froh
mein gott was ist das egal
das ist übertrieben das teilte spyker
wie verrückt oder days leute gucken
jetzt hat die rosenherz man jetzt die
unsere produkte hier bestimmt mal deine
hand
über twitter dass ihr hochwassers das
ist ein flummi anschein als ob tiger
bauern sehen wollte
ich bin fit aber oft nicht so gut sieht
aber keine ausweise und sehe dass hier
kann ich ja nach schenken rosa sternchen
dieses hilfrich gehen und im jugendtreff
schenken ist stimmt wenn junge könnte
viele leute sachen schicken ihre großen
blätter und vorlauten für touristen
können die jungs geschenkt ihr könnt
gelistete schenkt ihnen haben einander
immer sagen okay wir haben insgesamt
dreimal diese länder also die themen
sind irgendwie alle ich weiß nicht wir
haben nochmal jugend wenn du so lange so
ein motiv zum 25 ist und wann für diesen
mobilen 25 geburtstag heute also wenn
man das nicht immer auf die leute jetzt
macht ihr betrieb spart also mit benny
und wie man so kurz ist beschränkt also
das ist megageil leiter dann macht er
weiter
hier steht drauf man kann das vom band
hier man kann die nur darauf lesen heute
wird geübt was wird heute gemacht ja
sowas wirklich leute heute für natürlich
auch schon mega gespannt das heute wird
[Musik]
jungen da ist was kriege ich dafür wenn
ich sie so einfach auf die straße gehen
wenn ich so 1000
es wird der freude dass sich die leute
das ist sogar haben wir hier noch mal
zwei mal die andere auf 42 solcher
cupcake irgendwie wo man kaputt machen
kann hier kann man sogar zusammen falter
werden halt irgendwie fleisch boxen oder
sowas sondern wahrscheinlich sowieso mac
mini tüten roberts nach übertrieben
unnötig wird es nicht ein zu bestellen
ab heute wird beim nächsten stopp aller
zeiten wird immer punkt hier frage aber
rollen und nico schwanz des praktikums
einkaufen und wir waren wir dann so eine
döner laden und so birk eltern ob die
hochzeit einladen ihren sohn hat es
nicht für drei euro verkaufen unsere
tätigen polt traurig als 100 personen
vertraulich zu was auch immer traurig
auf das ist eindeutig kontrolleurs mit
ihrem hügel auf die zeit gekommen sich
die eigentlich mein gott leute geht
jetzt mache ich das hier das war einfach
in meinen überraschungspaket drin bis
jetzt keinen spaß
das sind warte mal allein in 500 1000
1500 2002 1500 3000 und 3500 4000 es
hört nicht auf man das sind keine ahnung
das sind mindestens mal 10.000 euro in
bar viel geld schaut leute da ist dass
man nicht das ist für seine dienste im
video hatte und das ist für die die
nachricht jetzt auch weil hat jeder
seine religion für bestimmte leute ohne
schwarze auch hier noch komplett echte
münzen dann sieht hier dass sie das
verkaufen dürfen hier ein euro münze die
täuschend echt aus ist eine echte euro
mit so ist es ja schon eine farbe des
komplexes heft so diese glitzern usmanow
das heimliche
hab da sind andere luftballons winter
mit laxey machen wir gehen jetzt auf das
ist so zwei tütchen wo man alles machen
kann
herbert kickl und das hier das ist
willkommen mit dem packen was ist das
denn
die liste wurde unnötig der stadt von
einem gesagt dass partie ist moment so
brok aber du kriegst richtig viel mit
einer neuen euro 5
aber inklusive versand also das ist
schon sehr laut
das brauche ich aber am wenigsten von
uns vorbei ich weiter flach hier ist ich
hab natürlich ist es so dass ihr könnt
ihr nochmal damit die schultüten minuten
die man wahrscheinlich für kinder mit
süßigkeiten befüllen kann sie sind aber
noch nicht
also im prinzip sind das schlecht
bearbeitete papierrollen krepppapier ich
glaube das ist sogar noch schlimmer als
das ist hier alles so speziell
werblichen so hatte die bombe eine
einschulung aber diese hochzeit das hier
brauchen wir für den 25 geburtstag dass
das hier immer und das hier ist
natürlich richtig zeit für das ist für
mich auch noch gut okay leute das war's
dann auch schon vom heutigen medien habe
ich gefallen es war wirklich wirklich
lustig ist das getan hat schaut bei
sebastian verwalten dass hier ein abo
der anlage dir das video und dann könnt
ihr jedoch ein anderes video anklicken
und hier unten aber dass die leute es
ist der wahnsinn
habt ihr schon zweimal